bill belichick was speaking recently to
the patriots official website about how
they managed to figure out a way to
contain the kansas city offense and we
spent a lot of time last week talking
about tyree killing the damage he's done
to the patriots defense and how
important it was
to shut him down here's bill belichick
do we have bill belichick talking about
we do have it what here's here's bill
belichick talking about what they did to
take away tyree kill in the afc
championship game really first third
down play of the game um we double
covered hill here and of course there
was
some of that in the game as well and you
can see that uh mahomes is looking over
here trying to you know trying to throw
the ball at saying this general area
somewhere you know and there's the
double coverage on hill
uh that gives our russian opportunity to
get there so we'll run the three-man
game inside and that's kyle van noy
coming around
into the pocket and and making tackle
and and if you're watching it on nbc sn
well you saw it if you're listening on
radio what happened there and they
showed this during the game the look
that they give is the single high safety
that's the one guy who plays deep center
field while everyone underneath is
either in tight zone or man coverage
right and that guy in single high safety
was immediately going over to the side
of the field where tyra kill was
providing double coverage of tyrae kill
and that forced patrick mahomes to hold
on to the football longer and that's
what they did to hold hill to one catch
for 42 yards and that that's an example
chris of what we've been hearing for
years about bill belichick he will find
what the other offense does best and
come up with a way to take it away yeah
he's brilliant that way and then you
know also brilliant to know okay yeah
maybe i have one of the best corners in
football and stefan gilmore but it's not
realistic for me to ask him to just go
around the field and cover maybe the
fastest guy in the history of the sport
one on one so he said you know what okay
and mike they did that defense there
almost every snap of the game until the
third quarter when they finally changed
up with a few new wrinkles here and
there but they double teamed tyree kill
with jonathan jones and mccourty over
the top and then they said you know what
okay stefan gilmore you shut down sammy
watkins jc jackson you take travis
kelsey and it threw kansas city for a
loop nobody had defended him like that
all year long especially on a consistent
basis you had certain plays where tyree
kill was doubled but new england
literally said first second down it
didn't matter we're doubling tyree kill
he's not going deep on us and then the
extra element that we saw there if you
were watching on tv and i'll explain to
all the the radio listeners was what
they did with the pass rush right he
kind of slides that in there oh then we
had a looping linebacker well that was
one of the other keys we talked about to
the game right was not letting mahomes
out of the pocket so that was a great
example of two things belichick did game
plan wise of keeping the homes in the
pocket and then taking away the number
one option slash number one threat uh on
that kansas city offense
and we talk about that now number one
because it confirms a lot of the things
we thought going into the afc
championship game but also it opens the
door now to trying to figure out what
bill belichick will do against the rams
offense and it was 17 years ago and that
game will be played 17 years to the day
after super bowl 36 when belichick came
up with a two-pronged approach to
shutting down the greatest show-offs on
turf i mean the greatest show on turf
when they dropped eight guys into
coverage and dared mike march to run the
ball and on top of that they were
physical with marshall faulk every
chance they could get every legitimate
hit they could apply to marshall faulk
they did it to bang him off and and
rough him up and keep him from
dominating the game and so i can see
them doing the same thing this time
right definitely because they've got the
passing game they've got todd gurley you
attack todd gurley hit todd gurley test
that knee that's code for attack that
knee and and
go after him whenever you can with
defensive linemen and linebackers but
also drop guys into coverage flood the
lanes and take away what jared goff is
going to try to do by getting the ball
to brandon cooks and robert woods and
josh reynolds that's exactly right i
mean i think there there's going to be
the two things first of all the beauty
of the rams offense is guys like if
you're seeing on tv here with cooks and
woods you know one's got 80 receptions
the one's got 86 receptions they're both
right around 1200 yards it's one five
touchdowns the other six touchdowns so
you can't put your eggs in all in the oh
we have to stop the robert cooks or
brandon cook's player uh because these
guys the beauty of the rams and what
mcveigh have in this duo is they're
interchangeable they can kind of do
everything so there's not like one
specific role for one guy like tyree
kill was the deep guy and sammy watkins
was really the shallow cross guy they
don't do that as much so again i think
they will play some man-to-man nobody
plays more man-to-man than the new
england patriots and guys like gilmore
and jc jackson and i'm just going to say
this right now that duo they are better
than akeeb to leave and marcus peters
right now at this point of their career
i'm sorry gilmore and jc jackson are
special and what they put they are under
a lot of pressure on a weekly basis so
they will certainly have to play some
man-to-man and match up that way but i
think the other thing mike that they
will really want to stop let's not
forget the rams are the number what
three rushing offense in football and i
think that's where bill's going to look
at the game and go we need to take away
this aspect not necessarily just because
of the run game but most of their
offense comes off of the run game right
the fake the speed sweep fake the run
play action pass fake the speed sweep
fake the run bootleg out to the edge
where if you were just watching on tv
you saw jared goff throw a few bootlegs
i think he's going to be more concerned
about playing like a bear front mic
right the bear front where you're gonna
put three big d lyman over the center
and the two guards and say okay you're
not running up the middle and then
they're gonna have guys on the edge
ready for
bootlegs play actions robert woods speed
sweeps that's where i think probably it
will start for for new england when they
start to break the rams down
so that means instead of dropping guys
into coverage you're going to be more
aggressive at the line of scrimmage i
trust gilmore and jackson to cover
cooks and woods and you know ultima
here's ultimately what happens
can you
do the thing
that belichick is trying to force you to
do because that's ultimately what he's
trying to do he wants to take away your
bread and butter he wants to take away
your easy yards your easy points and
force you to do something you don't want
to do force patron homes to roll to his
left instead of his right for example
forced patron homes to go somewhere
other than tyree kill you want to make
the players uncomfortable you want to
make the coaches uncomfortable what we
saw with super bowl 36 chris was mike
martz was too stubborn to take what bill
belichick was giving him right the
question is with sean mcvay who turns 33
today
bill belichick is 66 will mcveigh take
what belichick is giving him i i do
think he's smart enough to do that i
don't think you know mcveigh's ego is
out of control as maybe some of the off
other offensive geniuses in football or
in the history of football mcveigh is a
very intelligent guy uh and and from my
you know just experiences being around
him he's always open to ideas listening
that's why he's got other great coaches
on his staff he's not trying to be a
dictator he's trying to accumulate the
the best guys and the most knowledge he
possibly can you know i think the
the big thing there with like and we
always talk about this with new england
right mike is this the number one thing
you have to do when you play the new
england patriots i think when you go to
the super bowl is self scout thyself
right because belichick is going to be
all over some of your key plays and key
principles so if the receiver on the
left runs a post a lot and the receiver
on the right runs a deep cross a lot you
have to do opposites to start the game
at some point you gotta go hey receiver
on the left you're not running a post
we're gonna have you run a post corner
and the guy who runs the deep cross
we're gonna have you fake the cross and
come back out you're gonna have to do
things like that to go hey new england
you're not gonna sit here and just sit
on our bread and butter we got other
things off of this and you better be
ready to defend that as well i think
that's where it has to start for the
rams offense
it sounds like you almost have to be
prepared to whip up a new loaf of bread
and go find a new tub of butter i mean
and mcvay i think has the capacity right
to do that where you're basically coming
up with a new playbook just for
this game and and you have to wonder
because look at what happened with the
rams early on they emerged fairly
quickly this year as a team that was
going to be a serious contender and
mcveigh's smart enough to see how the
dominoes are going to fall and who he
may have to face and that belichick is
looming out there would it shock us to
know that mcvay has already had for
weeks now a plan cooked up for what he
would do kind of like that switch to
southpaw where bill belichick is ready
based upon everything he's seen all year
long and mcveigh is going to trot out
plenty of things that no one has seen
this year from the rams is that possible
i think it is possible i'm not going to
say that they've
dove into that at any point prior to
this week but i think that hey you're
playing new england patriots and we talk
about all the time how on a week-to-week
basis they change their game plan and do
things like that that's what makes them
great and you have to be able to match
wits with them in that capacity and this
is the this is why the two weeks of the
super bowl is great because now mcveigh
has a full week here of yeah they're
practicing but he really gets to tinker
with a lot of ideas and how he wants to
mess with this patriots defense and some
of the things bill likes to do as well
and yes we're gonna see what he's got in
the old you know bag of tricks here and
hopefully he can bring out something
interesting that keeps new england on
edge
yeah i mean and that's going to be part
of the fascinating impact of the game
and it's not going to manifest itself
while we're watching it's almost
something where after the fact you have
to look at the film and look at what the
rams are doing in comparison to what
they've done what works what doesn't
work but yeah it's it's two of the
smartest coaches in football it's just
one is exactly half the age
of the other
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports